you have ruminated on death you've got a
long way to go yet but um what will
death be like when it
comes well the best thing about death is
you won't know about it it's like being
stupid it's only painful for others so
I'm not bothered by it I I I don't care
about being dead I worry about how I die
yeah sure we we do Ponder the universe
and it always come back to us it always
comes back to us you know why are we
here why are we well we just are the
chance of us being born that sperm
hitting that egg is 400 trillion to one
we're not special we're just lucky and
there's loads of reasons why you can say
we're here um and uh it's it's more what
you do with it it's to to eat and drink
and make friends and have fun and learn
as you do make people laugh make people
laugh oh there's no better
privilege it it you know it's it's not
saving lives like a doctor or um
securing a beach head and and and
freeing um people from a tyny it may do
a lot more good than you're conceding
well we just want to get through life we
just want to we just want to think it
was worth along the way don't well I I I
just think that um when when uh you're
more unhappy than happy um there's
there's something wrong and you've got
to do something about it and if you're
if you're mostly happy then uh then keep
going you know and uh if if I stop
enjoying life or I have no quality of
life or I'm in pain um I I'll pop into a
chemist and take the pill hopefully
it'll be available by then the one that
um obviously everyone gets and I used to
be frivolous and I used to do not now I
just answer them seriously um uh if we
evolved from apes why are there still
Apes around I used to say things like
well if God made man from dust why is
there still dust around and things that
you know but now I say well we didn't
evolve from Modern Apes we evolved with
modern Apes from a common ancestor
rather like and I just answer it deadly
deadly serious like they you know it
doesn't help
then someone someone followed it up with
well I've been at the going to the same
Zoo for 24 years and I haven't seen one
monkey turn into a
person but I think I think even though
that's incredibly stupid we think
actually it shows what the problem is
when people try and understand they
can't grasp the scale of it they can't
imagine these tiny changes no one can
imagine 50 million years so they do
expect them to the chimp to go come on
lad get on with it and that's cuz they
also give it a will they they can't see
that it's nearly an analog thing as well
and and and uh I think you've spoken
about this before your your amazing
model about if you took a picture of
your dad and your grandparents and their
dad you any one point you go they look
alike but at some point is a fish you
know eventually there's a fish I didn't
see that coming but you did you to you
know it's so that they again it's the
it's the scale the scale is is
unimaginable it it's lucky that it did
happen cuz we couldn't imagine it if it
wasn't fact we couldn't make that up
you're not convicted of your atheism
sure am because atheism is only
rejecting the claim that there is a God
atheism isn't a belief system athe so
this this is atheism in a nutshell you
say um uh there's a God I say can you
prove that you say no I say I don't
believe you then so um you believe in
one God I assume uh in three persons but
go ahead okay so you believe okay so but
there there are about 3,000 to choose
from that have been you know people
believe done some reading yeah okay so
so basically you believe in you you you
deny one less God than I don't you don't
believe in
2,999 Gods and I don't believe in just
one more
right um I remember I did a sketch once
on the 11:00 show and it was about um uh
benefit uh cheats or means testing right
and the joke was um I I played an awful
sort of bigoted right-wing um news
reporter and I was going um we should
test them we should we should see if
they're really disabled we should tip
them out the wheelchair and set the fire
alarm off and see if they run right and
also if they say they're death they
might not even hear the fire alarm they
would all this sort of right and someone
um uh a lawyer or someone at Channel 4
said oh don't have a go at the death
they're very militant have go at the
blind so it was nothing to do with
morality it was like I'll have to write
more letters right and I go one the joke
doesn't work cuz blind people can hear
the fire alarm right like like but but
apart from that so so this this isn't to
do this is the thing about political
correctness it's not it's not
correctness it's political correctness
so it's often oh where do I get less
Flack you know so and
you I can defend everything I've ever
done you know I I'm not one say comedy
is your conscience taking a day off I
can defend every joke I've ever said
because offence usually comes when they
mean it let's first of all I think
political is good per se I don't want
people going around saying terrible
things and hurting people's feelings at
the time particularly politicians right
um uh so but in our it's different and a
joke is very different it's a very
different thing uh and when the offense
comes um
uh it's usually because they've mistaken
the target of the joke um with the
subject and they're not necessarily the
same thing particularly with irony and
with irony you're purposely saying the
wrong thing and you're hoping that
people are sensible and intelligent
enough to get it and laugh at the stupid
attitude so confusion comes okay uh but
you can't legislate against stupidity
you can only War a satire down so much
until it's not satire anymore and then
just standing up and preaching you're
stand up going racism's wrong a't it and
people go
yeah cheers good night you know
so um as long as most people get the
joke uh and it's getable and there there
is a basis for it and a reason for it
and there's a comic conceit and a and a
fair Target um you can't worry about
people not getting it or not liking it
because that's going to happen there's
nothing you can say that someone
somewhere doesn't like and most of its
taste it's just they didn't like it you
know um a a few examples uh uh I my
first my first um uh gig I think in the
new New York I made jokes about AIDS
cancer famine the
Holocaust uh everything right I did a
joke about um an Frank right the the
Nazis being so stupid they couldn't he
it in a book right okay and it was a
routine and I got a letter of complaint
from a Jewish Society saying we loved
your show but we did not appreciate the
I said I said so you you got the irony
with the famine cancer AIDS you did like
the of course I don't think that I did
the you know and and then they get they
go oh yeah sure okay and most people do
that but we're human so when we hear a
thing about what we think is us we go
well that that yeah that's we get it on
all the other stuff you can't see the
wood for the trees and that's human
right um but uh it it's crazy to worry
about one person thinking you mean them
when you don't you know I I tweeted once
um why did the chicken cross the road
hey [__] you my chicken died last night
you know so someone's going to be going
through some a your your joke is going
to remind people of a Bad Thing
everything should be subject to ridicule
yeah I mean as even just to force you to
understand think about it more I know
but people then they go uh wow um yeah
you shouldn't know people's feelings
well you can if their feelings are wrong
yeah you know get if you don't like the
facts get don't change the facts change
the feelings you know um and also they
then they try and do this thing oh you
should um you should never you should
never punch down you you should punch up
well who's to say what's up and down is
yeah yeah it's subjection so you're
you're you're deciding Who's down and
who's up no no no no no you you you
don't get to do that yeah no And so
there's this whole thing nowadays about
about not offending people and and and
and people feeling uncomfortable in the
states is a big thing with sort of
Target words and safe zones people don't
want to hear anything a word that they
don't like how arrogant are you to think
that you deserve to go through life with
no one ever saying anything that you
don't agree with or like it's not it's
you know but I think it's Pro it's at
least it's in the states I think it's a
property of upbringing where parents
sort of convince their kids when when I
was growing up I we played in the
streets right but now don't go in the
streets it's dangerous nothing should
ever you should ever take any risks and
nothing should ever you shouldn't do
anything that might might hurt you in
any way or make you uncomfortable in any
way and it education and science the
purpose of it is to make and a sense of
humor it makes you bulletproof you don't
have you don't have to pave the jungle
you can just grow up PA and have a laugh
about it I mean comedy comes first and I
and I understand well that's the other
thing people try and give ideas rights
yeah exactly so so you're not allowed to
offend their you know they jump in the
way of the bullet and say why are you
shooting at me right if someone insults
maths I don't go how dare you insult
maths insult at all you like it works if
you're so fragile that that you think
that a joke about someone can destroy it
whether you you need something else then
it it's nonsense and now people saying
you know um uh people mistake sometimes
demanding equality right by not being
part of humor yeah is actually demanding
um privilege
yeah it's it's nonsense but I I agree
it's it's someone says they're offended
I want people to stop saying that joke's
offensive I wanted to start saying I
found it offensive cuz you got to own
the emotion cuz that's all it is you're
just telling me how you feel about it
yeah have you seen a a change in your
over the last I 20 years or so about how
atheism is is perceived well I mean you
sort of do it I I there's part of me
that does it because I think I should
that there is someone being persecuted
now that might you know um I can't I
can't change the world but what I mean
maybe someone in a in a western world
that that thinks they shouldn't come out
because it's a bad thing because it's
still a bad thing in Western Society um
in America they took a vote America
right that probably that big bit in the
middle of America but um we were voted
least trustworthy group joint bottom
with
rapists so there's still a thing about I
bet not s I'm an atheist that annoy my
mom or dad or Granddad or school there's
still that so you do that some of it I
do it as an intellectual Pursuit cuz
someone asked me a question I'd rather
give the right answer than the wrong
answer I'd rather tell the truth than
lie because it's easier you know I think
the big thing people think I run into
churches and go it's all [__]
bollocks I I I I don't I don't care you
know I don't um but if I'm asked if I
believe in God I'll say no I mean you
know the tricky one is um um I I did a
film called The Invention of Lying where
I did a scene where my thank you seven
people saw that film um um where my
mother in that is dying and it's because
I'm the only person in the society can
lie she says I I don't want to go to
nothingness and I go there's not
nothingness it's a beautiful place you
go and you're young again and I invent
heaven right and that comes from the
fact that when my mom was dying I did
face a dilemma if she'd have said you
think there's a God that's that's a
personal thing and that's a you know um
uh so I yeah I I um I I try I just try
and be honest really um and the other if
if someone else's kid 5-year-old asks me
do I believe in God I sort of think what
should I say here and I say well I don't
but a lot of people do what do you think
you know I try and there's still a a
level of diplom it's not it's not always
my place you don't you know what I mean
I don't um but you know my house my
rules if someone ask me something on
Twitter I tell them the truth cuz you
know if there were three doors which God
exists God doesn't exist I don't know
that doesn't make sense there's three
doors it says God exists doesn't exist I
don't know but you not knowing is
irrelevant to where there is or isn't a
god you again you've done a slight of
hand there on a category mistake cuz one
is knowledge and two are beliefs right
finished question no what no no there's
always I'm saying three is always there
if you had to choose one yeah it's um I
I believe there's a God I don't believe
there's a God I don't know is irrelevant
then isn't
it so you're basically saying that we
have reached this stage p purely because
of social media that's the only reason
uh no it's just it's just another outlet
for narcissism that's all it's it just
amplifies things there's always been um
uh things that but you know uh 15 years
ago if you wanted to write a complaint
to the BBC you have F you get out your
pen go dear BBC I am I can't [__] be
bothered now you go you tweet something
someone else gets involved they get
involved a press person's reading it
they're doing it's a story because it's
a spur of the moment It's shouting out
of a window and someone shouting back
whereas we didn't have that before so
it's just it's about amplification it's
all about amplification and there's also
um uh a an equivalence and there's quite
a democracy on Twitter whereas
um someone you can have a genius you can
have Richard Dawkins tweet something and
underneath it is some Blok in a bin
tweeting summer in the same font and it
gives it an equivalence do you know what
I mean you you you've read them both
you've read them both you go right and
that can you know amplify and I think
you have to treat it like that you have
to treat it like you've walked past some
graffiti and it's for you to get
offended I've no one's ever hurt my
feelings on Twitter it would be like
right you imagine you walking down saval
row
right yeah yeah well I know you where I
know you hang
out um and there's a there's a man in a
bin covered in his own [__] and he
shouts
wanker imagine you getting into an
argument with him it's happened
yeah yeah but then on Twitter you that
suddenly you're you're in a discussion
with this guy on Twitter so you've
you've given him all this Credence you
know so so you've got to treat it like
that and and it's terrible with you know
some TRS really do Target people
vulnerable people and it's and it's
awful but if you turn your phone off
it's it's not there anymore and um I
think we have to treat these people like
you know that they should be treated
they are in a bin so in in the we're
chatting beforehand um I was checking
with some friends and and one of the the
questions came up about comedy and the
fact that we couldn't think of many if
any comedians who were
religious I'm not asking for example I'm
just saying is is do we think it's a
thing that most stand-ups tend to be
agnostic or atheist or I think so I
think that's because a lot of comedians
um uh are critical thinkers I think a
lot of them are science based um uh
they're intelligent well I don't want to
well yeah but yeah but then you know a
lot of a lot of religious people are
intelligence but they've been they've
been got at an early age and it's like
um yeah I think they're braver some
people there's still a thing of not
saying I'm an atheist because they cuz
people think that it's a bad thing to be
you know parents still Christen their
kids in school because they think it's a
respectable thing to do you know um and
I that that's sad but I get it um
there's a couple though there's a couple
they don't put it in their act I don't
think um uh Tim Vine is very devout
Christian true um yeah but General it it
they they tend to be I think more
skeptical or or I I think that's because
they are they look at things from all
angles and they come up with funny ideas
and I um uh and I try I I look at the
idea and I think that's that's what's
wrong and that's what Dogma does is that
people try and give ideas human rights
so you leave them alone and you you you
you don't have to you can ridicule ideas
without hurting anyone and some people
say that deserves a round of applause oh
than thank
you and uh and they and they found it
shut some people up if they say that's
hurt you know um you can be accused of
racism or anything if you if you CR
criticize an idea and it's people
jumping in the way of a bullet and
saying why are you shooting at me and it
comes back to Richard's point that um
I'm offended
that's not an argument it's not an
argument it's like me being offended if
someone takes the Mickey out of maths
it's
like go go on yeah fine yeah do you know
what I mean just you can laugh at math
it doesn't it doesn't affect maths it
doesn't affect
maths the other thing is this ridiculous
thing of um oh let's ask the average
person what they think let's stop asking
the average person what the do you know
how [__] stupid the average person
is we still sell bottles of bleach with
big labels on that say do not drink
right let's take those labels off right
for 2
years and then have a
referendum